[Música]
vamos ahora con nuestra primera invitada
del día y el tema que nos ocupa en esta
mañana es la previa de las elecciones de
Turquía que enfrentarán a su balotaje
este domingo el presidente de taller
verdogan el principal candidato de la
oposición que malequistar oglu ambos
lucharán en la segunda vuelta de estas
elecciones el 28 de mayo cuáles son sus
posibilidades Y cómo será la votación
vamos a conversar sobre este tema con
Zaira Badillo Castro ella es
historiadora de school off Oriental and
Africam studies de la Universidad de
Londres y le doy la bienvenida a Zaira
Gracias por estar en directo a América
gracias por la invitación para comenzar
erdogan recibió en los últimos días el
apoyo de sinanogan El 5,2% de votos que
recibió el tercer candidato representa
el capital en su opinión que le hacía
falta a erdogan para continuar con su
mandato
erdogan es una figura muy fuerte que
todavía es muy popular en Turquía lleva
20 años gobernando y anterior a eso fue
alcalde de Estambul a mí me parece que
la oposición ha hecho un buen trabajo en
confrontarlo en en visibilizar unos
puntos en disidencia con con el discurso
de erdogan pero me parece que el apoyo
que la ha recibido en los últimos
semanas de otros partidos
ultranacionalistas lo van a poner en una
mejor posición para consolidar su poder
en las próximas elecciones no obstante
aunque muchos analistas hemos visto que
el hecho de que la oposición no haya
podido ganar las elecciones lo vemos lo
hemos visto a veces como un fracaso Yo
creo que es un frente muy importante hay
que entender que esto es una coalición
de distintos grupos que tienen
ideologías muy diferentes así que más
bien lo que han lo que han hecho es una
coalición un bloque en contra la figura
de erdogan que ya está desgastada pero a
pesar de eso pues un líder muy fuerte no
olvidemos que Turquía a pesar de que
estos comicios electorales demuestran
mayor eh mayor democracia no porque hay
una variedad de opiniones y de dicción
en la Esfera pública no deja de ser un
país sumamente autoritario donde erdogan
controla los medios donde hay una
persecución a los periodistas y donde
también control sobre las figuras de
oposición que pueden poner sombras sobre
erdogan Así que vamos a poderlo de esta
forma dentro del contexto autoritario Me
parece que erdogan sufrió una derrota al
no haber podido ganar contundentemente
en su primera en su primera la primera
ronda de elecciones pero en esta segunda
Ronda de elecciones Me parece que ya ha
podido consolidar su poder ya podido
establecer alianzas con miembros de la
digamos nacionalistas en en Turquía y me
parece que sigue siendo un hombre fuerte
que lo la población turca Mira él En un
momento de mucha inestabilidad
recordemos el terremoto de febrero no
olvidemos la guerra en Rusia y el rol
que ha jugado erdogan en mantener un
balance no de negociación entre la otan
Ucrania y la federación rusa así que me
parece que es un momento muy delicado no
solamente para el pueblo Turco también a
nivel internacional ver hay que entender
que cualquier cambio político en la
Esfera política de Turquía
independientemente de que la figura de
oposición más o menos mantiene una
opinión
una política exterior similar a la de
erdogan va a mantener la neutralidad que
ha mantenido a pesar de que el líder de
la oposición consideran que Turquía debe
moverse más hacia hacia tu hacia hacia
la Unión Europea me parece que es
importante que miremos estas elecciones
No pues es que usted acaba de hacer una
radiografía no solamente nacional sino
internacional Pero bueno vamos a tratar
de ir Punto por punto en los minutos que
nos quedan los kurdos constituyen
alrededor de una quinta parte de la
población de Turquía y han sido sin duda
vistos como cruciales para para las
esperanzas de la oposición de poner fin
a los 20 años el mandato de erdogan
usted opina que podrán hacer la
diferencia este domingo o al final es
simplemente Cuál será su papel aún
dentro de un nuevo gobierno de erdogan
Bueno es un papel importante pero no
olvidemos que el pueblo Turco es un
pueblo que ha sufrido los embates del
terrorismo que hasta cierto punto No
no sea sola solidarizado por completo
con la causa kurda No lo la población
curda sigue siendo discriminada
enormemente en Turquía y está asociada
con unos grupos terroristas y con
ciertos atentados que ocurrieron en los
noventa y en los 2000 por lo tanto es
también un grupo que tiende a dividir la
oposición a erdogan No porque se tiende
a asociar ahora la oposición con grupos
que apoyan la causa turca kurda perdón y
que hasta cierto punto No han condenado
abiertamente el grupo el partido de los
trabajadores kurdos que es ilegal en
Turquía por lo tanto es un arma de doble
filo sí Los kurdos representan un grupo
muy importante en ciertos sectores de
Turquía Pero también es un grupo que
puede que ha causado mucha división en
el electorado Turco que vea erdogan como
una figura que ha podido controlar los
ataques terroristas y que hasta cierto
punto erdogan se ha aprovechado de eso y
ha empezado a hablar de
de bueno de de que hay que compartir el
terrorismo y que el partido opositor
pudiese no tener la misma fuerza en en
perseguir los elementos terroristas de
los cursos en en Turquía por lo tanto ha
traído ese elemento que es muy peligroso
no Y eso ha causado división por lo
tanto yo creo que que la decisión de la
oposición de apoyar al movimiento curdo
de incluirlo ha sido muy positivo Pero
también es algo que erdogan se ha
aprovechado también Pues digamos estos
nacionalismos no que está siempre
movilizando tanto erdogan pese a todos
los años que llevan el poder y ese
desgaste que usted menciona ahora muchos
pensaron que la crisis del costo de vida
en Turquía dificultaría el apoyo erdogan
sin embargo eso finalmente no pasó y
veremos el resultado en las elecciones
de este domingo porque sigue calando
tanto esta figura de erdogan alrededor
del nacionalismo de la religiosidad y
pues de Decisiones extremas que usted
bien describía en la primera pregunta
bueno la crisis económica en Turquía es
real ya hace dos años no el costo de
vida en la ciudad de Estambul para el
transporte público O sea triplicado
cuatriplicado no todos los productos
más básicos de la dieta turca también
son sumamente costosos la guerra en
Ucrania también ha tenido sus
repercusiones en Turquía y erdogan tiene
una política contrario a Bueno también
que intercede o decir se entromete mucho
en las decisiones del Banco Central algo
que que es muy se le critica mucho no
Entonces ha exigido que no se suban las
las tasas de interés mantener Las bajas
cuando alrededor del mundo muchos otros
bancos centrales han subido las tasas de
interés para controlar la inflación por
lo tanto
erdogan se ha ido más por medidas
más que lo favorecen no no Exacto por lo
tanto no ha pensado tanto en la
población y el y el sufrimiento que que
han pasado pero yo creo que las
elecciones le va a hacer le va a obligar
a hacer un cambio Bueno pues veremos qué
pasa el domingo veremos qué pasa después
porque una cosa es el candidato y otra
cosa es el gobernante gracias a usted a
esa era Badillo Castro historiadora para
France 24 y para directo a América que
le vaya muy bien gracias a nuestros
televidentes continúen con nosotros ya
regresamos con más
[Música]